what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a new update about the
trial of Jonathan Majors today Jonathan
Majors appeared in court virtually and
today they set yet another court date
for the trial now something seems to be
shifting though in the way that people
are now starting to report about this
case and specifically how they speak of
Jonathan majors and I think that after
all of the evidence in his favor has
come out now it seems like more and more
people are starting to believe him but
of course until they have the trial and
the court and the judge decides until he
is guilty or innocent of course nothing
really matters however how people view
him now will ultimately matter after the
trial and it is actually good to kind of
see this shift with the news outlets
reporting about him and his case and
we'll break down why this is good and
we'll break down what happened today the
trial unfortunately is delayed again
however this time it's not by that long
fortunately but we'll break down what
you need to know in this video and if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on the trial of Jonathan
majors and for the latest MCU news also
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month so as far as I can tell the
first people to report about this was
deadline and the article starts off by
stating almost six months after Jonathan
Majors was arrested in New York City on
domestic violence charges the start of
the Creed 3 actors trial on the matter
was today pushed yet again a very short
hearing Wednesday Today determined that
another hearing will now be held on
September 15th to set a new trial date
in theory so first and foremost like I
said they did meet today and Jonathan
Majors appeared in court virtually and
they have decided to yet again delay the
start of this trial and they decided to
do this and they have decided to do this
because Jonathan Majors attorneys say
that they found deficiencies with the
certificate of compliance that the
prosecution against Jonathan major filed
and we'll explain what this means in
just a bit but let's get through the
article first this next part is where I
noticed that the reporting is kind of
viewing Jonathan majors in a little bit
of a different way now they stayed after
numerous delays today was supposed to be
the actual start of the actors trial on
the misdemeanor charges stimming from
the incident in and around his Chelsea
apartment on March 25th though he was
the one who called 9-1-1 back in the
spring the king the Conqueror actor is
looking at up to a year behind bars if
found guilty on the claims prosecuted by
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg's office so
here they are actually addressing that
Jonathan Majors was the one to call the
police for the situation and for those
who may not know the full situation the
situation was when he went back home to
his apartment he found the woman his ex
Grace Jabari passed out drunk and half
naked on the floor of his closet earlier
they were in a private car together in
which he left and reportedly he left
because she was trying to see his phone
and started to kind of attack him trying
to see so he left her and he did not
return to his apartment till later on in
the morning but she went out clubbing
and there is video footage of this and
tons of pictures of this as well so it's
nice to see that they are kind of being
a little less biased now because when
the reports first came out everybody was
stating Jonathan Majors is guilty he did
all this and now he's going to court it
just pretty much sounded like everybody
had wrote him off and said that he was
guilty right away because of what was
presented in the very first report
however now it does seem like everybody
is remaining pretty neutral which is a
good sign because that means a lot of
people have seen all the evidence that
has come out recently and are thinking
well maybe he's not guilty again we're
not 100 sure until the trial happens and
all the evidence is presented but it is
nice to see people being a little
unbiased now and there's even more of
that in the article they continue to
State the defense team has made repeated
efforts to turn the spotlight onto the
character and motivations of the 30 year
old woman who was in the apartment with
Majors on March 25th speaking of his
ex-girlfriend race Jabari current
girlfriend at the time they stayed on
the scene that night NYPD officers
reported the now ex-girlfriend of Majors
suffered minor injuries to her head and
neck from the incident notwithstanding
any Litany of proclamations and
predictions by chaudhry's office in the
months since not to mention leaked video
footage of the woman out clubbing that
weekend the ex-girlfriend in question
has not been arrested by the police so
even here they state that the NYPD said
that she suffered injury and Trauma and
they reported it was from him which is
why they arrested him but she was seen
out clubbing after she reportedly got
harassed and abused because they
reported this happened in the car that
they were sharing however like I
mentioned before Jonathan Majors exited
that car and walked away from the
situation and then the woman still went
out clubbing despite reporting several
injuries and in the footage and the
pictures that we've seen of it she seems
perfectly fine she is using the hand
that was reportedly injured multiple
times holding drinks in her hand and
according to Jonathan Major's legal team
there is streets CCTV footage of him
exiting the private car that they hired
and footage of her trying to pull him
back in but eventually he gets away and
they say he was very calm and collected
and people even stop him on the street
and ask him for a photo in which she
lets them he takes a photo with them
very kindly and willingly and this is
according to majors's law team so even
this report by deadline is stating Well
they claimed one thing but there is
video footage out there kind of showing
a different thing so you could see how
the media is kind of turning now and
trying to remain impartial on the
subject which of course is how it should
be until a decision is made in court and
even recently you might have noticed the
past couple of days Marvel Studios has
released a new TV spot for the Loki
series which shows a lot of Jonathan
majors's King variant Victor timely
before Marvel Studios and Disney were
kind of putting off any type of
promotion or marketing that had Jonathan
majors in it or even the mention of his
character Kang for the promotions of
Ant-Man and the wasp and the credits and
the description on Disney plus all they
had was the credit to Jonathan Mages for
playing King but in the description of
what the movie was about they even
removed King the Conqueror they just
simply talked about a villain and a
threat so they've changed a little bit
on that side as well now including him
in the full promotions for Loki season
2. and as far as this is concerned I
want to clarify that this is just
speculation on my part now but it is
possible that Jonathan majors and his
legal team met with Marvel Studios of
course to try and explain to them what
happened if what they claim is true and
he is innocent and they do have all the
evidence that they've said they have
they could have gone to Marvel Studios
in Disney in order to keep and protect
his job and his role as king the
Conqueror and presented all of that
evidence and said something along the
lines of please don't make an official
decision until the trial happens and a
judge makes a decision because they
believe that Jonathan Majors is indeed
innocent and if he is indeed innocent he
should not be punished and should be
allowed to keep his role as Kane the
Conqueror in the MCU and he's already
lost other jobs as well and he's been
dropped by his management and PR Company
and deadline and even The Hollywood
Reporter both report that Disney is
indeed now even including him in the
marketing but they also do acknowledge
that he has lost jobs and has been
dropped from some of his representation
now the last time the trial was delayed
Jonathan Major's team said that they
were fully ready for the trial to begin
it was the other side the prosecution
that said they needed more time to
gather evidence this time the
prosecution stated that they were ready
for the trial but the defense lawyers
for Jonathan Majors stated in court that
they found deficiencies in Discovery
that still needed to be addressed with
the certificate of compliance now a
certificate of compliance and Court
means that a report provided by the
agency to the office of the state
auditor states that the grantee has met
the reporting requirements and according
to Jonathan majors's team when the
prosecution submitted that they found
themselves deficiencies in it we don't
know what they are we don't know what it
can mean but this is why the trial is
delayed and again it is set to September
15th so not another month away not a few
months away only 10 days away from now
so hopefully then we learn a lot more
about what exactly is happening for this
trial but again Jonathan Majors his team
continued to state that he is indeed the
victim here that he did not harass her
or abuse her or assault her in any type
of way and they claim that they have the
evidence to support that and of course
if we hear anything else in the meantime
we'll of course do an update video about
it and of course we'll update you on
September 15th as well so to stay up to
date be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos please don't
forget to like the video and of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well as always thank you all
so much for watching
thank you